[Musique]
à vos manettes avec fantasy bol c'est un
peu de la réunion que vous avez entre
les mains un jeu vidéo qui prend place
dans un univers assez original fantaisie
en arène avec des personnages
fantaisistes un magicien un chevalier un
archet etc le but c'est tout simplement
de marquer le plus de buts possible
pendant la le temps de la partie voilà
pour le décor mais pas de pelouse verte
ici on s'affronte en famille au milieu
d'un volcan sur un bateau pirate ou
encore à la plage et tout a été
développé au port par une équipe de 5
passionnés formés à lillois l'Institut
de l'image de l'océan Indien le jeu a
pris 6 mois de développement j'ai
d'abord travaillé seul pendant deux mois
et demi puis ensuite quatre personnes
m'ont rejoint un artiste 3D deux
artistes 2D et un samedi designer pour
s'occuper de toute la partie graphique
la partie visuelle du jeu et sonore et
Arnaud Bruz s'envole ce soir pour Paris
puis pour les États-Unis à San Francisco
où il pourra présenter son jeu à la GDC
l'un des plus grands salons dédiés aux
professionnels du jeu vidéo l'ensemble
des développeurs du monde entier vont à
cette convention pour essayer de nouer
des liens professionnels et ça va être
mon objectif d'essayer de représenter
déjà la Réunion et de créer des liens
professionnels entre les studios
réunionnais et les studios
internationaux il ne sera pas le seul à
représenter notre île à ce salon à ses
côtés deux autres réunionnais Laurent
Medea et Kevin à lamelou déjà rencontré
sur le salon du Geek Ali à la Norvège